and now the panthers have to figure out
what to do with this contract that has
10 million fully guaranteed with another
7 million in salary on top of it it
occurred to me yesterday i see three
destinations chris and i want to run
these by you yeah number one number one
and and two are via trade one is via we
just have to cut the cord on this guy
and eat the 10 million dollars but
trading to the broncos reunited with
former vikings assistant gm george
payton and agreed to be an upgrade over
drew locke you like it yeah or he
competes with him right if drew lock
like falls apart early in the year and
it's two gunslinger now you got the guy
teddy bridgewater who's the opposite of
that to go oh hey we're gonna play
through the defense and i'll manage the
game so that makes a lot of sense i'm
with you there
now to get that deal done i think what
teddy would have to do is take less than
17. and maybe the panthers would have to
pay part of the 10. but you know what
you get a chance to walk in the door and
compete to be a starter and no one else
is paying you 17 this year you're
getting your 10 from the panthers one
way or the other no one's paying you 17.
how much more over 10 are you willing to
take less than 17 to land in a spot
sooner rather than later this is the
trent brown dynamic where the panthers
can say hey we don't have to cut any
time soon you either do this deal make
this happen or we're eventually going to
dump you and you're going to be capped
at 10 million the other team and
remember this team came up
at some point
during march as potentially interested
in teddy bridgewater and that's the
49ers and there's still a way to do this
where you dump garoppolo and his 25
million you get teddy bridgewater and
you pay him 12.
and it's easier for bridgewater i submit
chris to be the short term
he starts until the rookies ready right
then run the risk that garoppolo is
going to be healthy and effective and
you got a problem in the locker room
you're not going to have a problem in
the locker room if garoppolo is gone
bridgewater comes in knowing the
assignment knowing what his role is
it's easier to pull that off if you're
kyle shanahan and it's it's 50 cents on
the dollar right in comparison to the 25
million garoppolo supposed to make if
you can get teddy to take 12. yeah my i
mean that makes a lot of sense it does i
mean it makes sense from the 49er
standpoint i think you're you know spot
on there you know the denver thing
certainly you know again where i'll go
back with you know the 49er thing is you
know that that makes a lot more sense as
far as having jimmy there right just
because he's already got a flag planted
in the ground he's established they've
gone to the super bowl with him that's
gonna cause a little bit more of a
ruckus in the locker room than teddy
bridgewater coming and you're going okay
yeah he's good but we don't know this
guy and yeah we have a rookie
quarterback who's the number three pick
in the draft and okay that's right we
like teddy but you know he'll play when
he has to or whatever are you agreeing
or disagreeing with my thought that it
would be less of a problem in the locker
room i agree
i agree yes i was saying yes it's too
much of an issue with garoppolo because
he's already planning a flag in the
organization so i agree with you and
then hey the other team too just to just
because i know we both got this on our
radar still is we'll see what happens
with seattle i just know there's a lot
of people in the nfl in league circles
that do not think that story's done yet
and if they decide to trade him maybe
that becomes a place where carolina has
some conversations with seattle and they
get something done and teddy goes up
there and hey he would fit teddy he
would fit that style of football you
know as far as pete carroll want to run
the ball play through the defense manage
the game do those type of stuff i mean
that that certainly would fit seattle's
style
the four teams that russell wilson's
agent identified four or five weeks ago
seemingly are out of it at this point
although i guess the raiders could still
get back into it it just doesn't seem
like there's a lot no of teams out there
right now now with russell wilson maybe
you tear up the plans that you have and
you say
unless you've got a clear franchise guy
you say okay yeah we thought it was
going to be andy dalton but now the
seahawks all of a sudden are willing to
take our three first-round picks when
they weren't before or whatever the case
may be yeah right
i just feel like there's no other than
the dolphins other than the dolphins
uh who seemingly are sending the message
that they're fine with tuatanga vialoa
by trading out of the three spot right
you can't rule out the possibility
that they're going to take all these
extra picks they have now
and maybe still try
to make a move for russell wilson if
that would somehow somehow play out but
clearly the jets aren't in play at this
point that was a team that i was
intrigued by as a potential russell
wilson destination because it was a
couple of years ago he was talking about
the giants so there was noise about the
giants right but the the the music is
slowing down the seats are filling up
and the one other team that i had in
mind with teddy bridgewater you
mentioned the buccaneers bruce arian
said last year yeah it was tom brady
teddy bridgewater jameis winston that
was the priority right and if you cut
teddy bridgewater
he could just go to tampa bay and take
the minimum 1.075 million the panthers
are paying the difference and he can be
the backup to tom brady hang around
there for a while see if maybe he can
become the guy after brady's gone yeah i
think that is the the ultimate
opportunity in the event that there
isn't a starting path somewhere right go
back up tom brady and make the panthers
pay the difference between what the
bucks pay
and and what teddy's gonna get by way of
the 10 million dollars yeah no i mean
there's a lot of options here the there
there definitely is uh
you know yeah i think teddy the starter
that that's probably
by the way side unless it becomes in
denver where he goes goes to denver gets
traded there gets to compete with drew
lock and do all of that you know so yeah
we'll see where that goes but i would
expect something to go down there you
know before the draft or at least right
after the draft or during the draft i
don't expect them to be on the roster
you know once the draft is over you know
and then when you're the seattle thing
and russell wilson like yeah i'm with
you man i don't know like where where
does that end up you know right now
there really is nothing other than miami
the other only other team i look at a
little just to go was wait wait they
could still they're still looking for
their quarterback of the future is
washington
you know but again i don't know if
they're gonna be in the the class for a
russell wilson the way washington's
sitting there right now they're probably
sitting there wait one of these five
quarterbacks might fall to us at number
19 or 20. i can't remember which one
they are exactly and maybe they'll get
them there yeah so we'll see
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports